in the beginning the earth was without
form and void the sunshine upon the
sleeping earth into the swirling
maelstrom of fire air and water the
first stirrings of life appeared the
seeds of life grew and strengthening
spread and diversified now it required
but one more ingredient a raisin leader
to unite the quarreling tribes but to
harness the power of the land to build a
legacy that will stand the test of time
a civilization
and so it falls upon you to fulfill our
people's true destiny under your
leadership we shall surely prosper from
the seeds of this small settlement shall
you grow our Empire our people away to
your command
with these builders we will forge our
civilization piece by piece across the
land basic agriculture provides
much-needed sustenance and stability for
our people
Farms may also be added over resources
such as rice fields to further develop
our lands quarry's provide greater
access to building materials increasing
our insight in construction our builders
efforts are not in vain beyond
developing the surrounding area we may
now make improvements to the city itself
advancements such as granaries and water
wheels better the lives of our people we
are now ready to expand our reach beyond
our borders
these brave settlers are ready to carry
our culture into the unknown
the lands before is are filled with
untold resources and dangers we must
choose the site of our next city
carefully
gazing upon the ocean our new city's
inhabitants already plan on how they may
rule the waves however alone and
isolated this new city will not prosper
to truly thrive we must become one
people these traders allow us to connect
our people exchanging resources between
our cities brings with it great advances
it is the dawning of a new age
our cities are now free to develop as
never before
for the first time our civilization
spreads beyond the heart of our cities
allowing for the creation of new
districts
each with its own focus and distinct
advantages religious districts
strengthen the faith of our people
inspired to create true wonders within
our lands we push our civilization to
new heights
and find that we are capable of true
oneness
but our cities do not always need to
follow the same path where one looks
inward for enlightenment
the other focuses are more pragmatic
concerns
the creation of this district allows for
the greater protection of our people
barracks provide much-needed combat
advantages further bolstering our forces
for there will always be those who wish
to destroy all we have accomplished
barbarian forces continually prey on our
lands thankfully we are now prepared
our warriors are well-trained but this
is just a raiding party to ensure the
safety of our borders we must defeat the
enemy at its source
victory our people are secure and upon
these once untamed grounds our
civilization groves
a new age is upon us and we find
ourselves but one part of a larger world
we are no longer alone
welcome to the United States of America
if you conduct yourself well you can
consider us friends
this new world presents us with new
possibilities our neighbors have access
to resources we desperately need a trade
agreement here benefits both our people
as our relationships and resources grow
so too must our own leadership we may
now enact new policies to further steer
the growth of our civilization beyond
military and economic growth there are
also the cultural needs of our people to
consider
as culture advances new opportunities
present themselves to us the theater and
arts district allows our people to
express themselves as never before
you
the results are breathtaking
truly we have achieved a golden age of
peace and cooperation
but as with all things this golden age
cannot last the Industrial Age brings
great advancements but also great need
for resources cooperation becomes
competition we find our world shrinks
now more than ever we must make the most
of what land and resources we do have
this industrial district is key to
maximizing our production capabilities
but these mechanical marbles require new
sources of power fuel is now as valuable
as food in this industrial age while we
are fortunate other civilizations are
not they view our prosperity with
jealous eyes um up ie minik set him a
moon rah and end
our enemy knows as well they have hit us
close to heart
destroying valuable resources
still we are not without our own forces
the days of spear and arrow along since
behind us it is time we show this
invader our true night
well done but this enemy cannot be left
to lick its wounds and fight again our
onslaughts
must be absolute
you came at Nijo t earrin answer hey
nice pie e mirror say hey Nenana who to
the victor goes the spoils our
civilization heals and grows more
powerful
as our people advance we realize that
our future may hold more possibilities
than combat
we discover our true potential
and achieve greatness
in this new age our people truly surpass
expectation or until finally
go forward
to the next chapter of our destiny
you